hello everyone and welcome to Khan
Academy live SAT class I'm Eric and I'm
an SAT tutor and one of the SAT experts
here at Khan Academy I'm super excited
to join you today for our third and
final class on SAT writing we had an
earlier class on SAT math and one on SAT
reading and if you miss those classes
don't worry we have those in our YouTube
channel you can check them up but for
today the focus is all about SAT writing
and there's a lot to cover so let's take
a look at the schedule for the day so
for today the first 25 minutes I'm going
to spend on instruction and practice
problems and so I'll give you an
overview of the SAT writing test so you
know what to expect and share a few tips
about how you can mark it up so what are
you underlining boxing and so forth then
we'll cover subject verb agreement and
we'll do some practice problems here and
then I'll wrap up there with some
sentence punctuation and so these are
two important concepts that come up
quite commonly on the SAT writing and
language section and now after that all
spend ten minutes doing Q&A and so I'll
answer your questions that you have and
then I'll share the badge with you as
well that you're inviting Pete
completing the class then at that point
we have something a little bit different
and so you get to pick what you think
will help you most and so the first
option you'll have at that point to wrap
up the class is the head over to Khan
Academy to practice what you've learned
and at the same time you'll have access
to one-on-one chat support from our
wonderful Khan Academy and College Board
staff or the other thing you can do is
stay on YouTube and watch me work
through a writing passage from start to
finish and so again you said the last 25
minutes you can practice what you
learned yourself on Khan Academy or
watch me work through a writing passage
so that's the schedule for today there's
a lot to cover as you can see and I'm
excited to get started so let's jump in
so what can you expect on the writing
and language test well it's a 35 minute
section with 4 passages with 11
questions each and so you've got 44
questions
to deal with
the passages will have a few topic so
you can add any of these topics you see
here history humanities science or
career focused ones and then you have a
few passage types as well and so
argument questions will try and you know
argue appoint with evidence narrative
passages will tell you a story
whereas informative and explanatory as
it sounds like we'll just try to educate
you about a topic that you might not
have known about before then I want to
finally cover question types which are
very important and so there are two
questions hypes
on FAQ writing and the first is the
expression of ideas and so these ask you
to improve the effectiveness of
communication in the passage and so this
will ask you to increase things like the
flow the order the logic we have clarity
things like that and the second type of
question focuses on standard English
conventions and so they'll ask you to
make sentences in the passage consistent
with grammar usage punctuation and other
rules and so I really want to before I
wrap this one up emphasize that the SAT
writing and language test is not just
about grammar there that is a part of it
but expression of ideas clarity of
communication is also really highlighted
so let's keep going then
and now I'll cover how to markup the
test now that you know what to expect in
passages and I in the different question
types what how can you interact with the
test let's take a look so how you can
mark up the test they're probably four
tips that I would share with you so the
first is to annotate the passage as you
go and so this involves circling
underlining boxing things like
transition words or topic sentences so
transitions or topic sentences are
important as well the second tip I have
is to underline the question and the
answer traces so this underlining the
question will help you understand
obviously the question but then
underlining the answer choices will also
help you break things up and if you
can't read this and it's fuzzy on your
screen don't worry we'll get a chance
practice this in real life in just a bit
and then the third tip I have is to
cross out words to simplify long
sentences so often you have things like
prepositional phrases prepositional
phrases that are part of sentences but
they really don't affect the meaning or
the grammatical correctness and in fact
can make it harder to understand this
sentence and so we'll walk through an
example of what it looks like to spot
prepositional phrases and cross them out
to simplify and then the final tip I
would have is just to use process of
elimination so the moment you decide
that it answered it's a choice a a belt
cross it out or BC so that it really
saves you a lot of brain power and
processing time so you're not going back
in thinking wait did I already look at
this answer choice or not and so once
you've eliminated something and go ahead
and cross it off the list so those are
just a few tips for how you can mark up
the test and we'll get a chance to apply
marking up in annotating and process of
elimination later today but for now I
want to walk through subject verb
agreement which is a very common concept
that's tested and I'm sure you've heard
a bit about it in your reading class but
I'll give you a refresher and then we'll
do some practice problems so subject
verb agreement so to start as a
background you want to remember that
complete sentences must have a subject
and verb that agree now before I go any
further a quick reminder a subject is
the person place or thing that is doing
or being something so you know that is
doing or being the action and then the
verb is the part of the sentence that
expresses the action so those are every
complete sentence has to have both of
those parts it doesn't have one one of
those parts it is incomplete sentence
now when I say agreement what do I mean
well I mean that singular subjects have
to go to singular verbs and pull' plural
subjects with plural verbs and you'll
get a we'll get to do some practice on
this in just a minute but for now there
are two quick tips I want to share with
you so when I approach subject
for agreement questions I find it really
helpful to find the subject of the
sentence first then check for agreement
and so this one is very straightforward
right so what is the more
straightforward what is the subject here
we have the dog right so that's the
subject and then what is the action bark
so that is the verb they're these this
is will obviously get more complicated
so stay tuned the next tip I share is to
cross out unnecessary words to simplify
sentences so this one's a bit longer but
it reads the dog along with the cat was
convinced that it was nap time so now
for those at home what is the subject
here is it just the dog is it the dog
along with the cat so answer is that it
is just the dog so along with the cat is
a prepositional phrase that does not
create a compound subject and so it's
just the dog that's doing the action and
then the verb is was so if you cross out
the prepositional phrase the sentence is
a bit simpler and just reads the dog was
convinced that it was not time and then
you can tell that the agreement is fine
and eliminating the prepositional phrase
really helps so that's a quick overview
of subject verb agreement like I said
you've probably heard this in your
reading or English classes and it's cool
but this is a quick refresher and now
we're going to do a little back and
forth quiz see what you remember and
show you some examples so subject verb
agreement game we're going to play today
is is this singular or is this plural
and so I'm going to go through these one
by one and give you a chance to reply
and then I'll reveal the answer so he or
she that one is singular and that one's
more straightforward we're just
referring to one person there what about
anyone or each one that one is also
singular and the kind of the way I
remember it is I see this one I see the
one makes it a little easier to remember
okay now what about we we is plural so
you know multiple people you've got a
few stick figures here
like that now what about everyone and
everybody singular or plural so this one
is actually singular and I wanted to
include this one because it can seem
like it's plural because that you're
referring to it seems like I've got a
lot of people and everyone and everybody
but this is what's called an indefinite
pronoun and you don't need to
necessarily remember that term but you
do need to remember that everyone and
everybody 10 is singular now moving on
what it would up somebody somebody is
again is singular and so it's the same
situation as above and it's also an
indefinite pronoun and so that is you'll
want to remember that when you're on the
SAT now what about the turkey as well as
the chicken is that singular or plural
so this one is also singular means now
why is that well the subject of this
phrase is actually just turkey and as
well as the chicken is one of those
prepositional phrases again that do not
create a compound subject and so if you
just have one turkey there the turkeys
by themself it's a singular subject now
last example here James and I the
singular or plural
this one is plural so the important word
here is an so and is a conjunction
and that conjunction creates a compound
subject creates a compound subject so
excuse the handwriting subject and
compound subject like he and I she and I
are all plural since you're referring to
multiple people but a conjunction is
different from a prepositional phrase
and so these are just a few examples
that you want to make sure you
understand so you say there's some
easier ones like he or she but you want
to make sure you understand someone
everyone each one all of those different
cases and that will make sure you cover
your bases for the SAT so we've done
some back and forth now but we haven't
yet seen an SAT question so let's do
some practice problems so let's take a
look at this film in a little bit to
make it easier to see and so what I want
to do here is read the sentence and
underline it before I go any further
so Billy although he had a great sense
of timing for stand-up comedy were
handicapped by his poor memory so again
the what I want to do here is find the
subject subject where is the subject
well so who what or who is doing the
action in this case well it's going to
be Billy over here so that's the subject
and then I want to look at the verb here
so that's were and so then the other
thing I can do here is simplify is cross
this whole part out and so I know what
the subject is I know what the verb is
and so then I have Billy were
handicapped by his poor memory and then
that you can tell word does not agree
because that's plural and you want it to
be singular and so this should be was
Billy was handicapped and so then you
can do that and what you saw what you
saw me do there would figure out what
the sentence meant what the different
parts are and then by honing in on the
error and fixing it it allowed me to go
straight to the answer choice and
pinpoint those the right one here rather
than going through each one and so
that's one way you can save time and
it's a it's one way you can speed things
up as you're on SAT writing tests now
that was a good warm-up question let's
try one a little a little bit more
challenging and see what that's like so
let's take a look at this with the help
of the mat-su Regional Medical Center
middle school students in Gateway Alaska
observed intubation and sets bones so
again what is my subject so who or what
for what seeing is doing the action so
with the help of Matthew Regional Center
middle school students okay so middle
school students he
is my subject and what are they doing
they are observing intubation and
setting bones
so those are my verbs and and this is
the one that's underlined so I want to
pay extra attention here and just to
simplify I've got another one of those
prepositional phrases here so in gateway
Alaska I don't need to worry about that
it doesn't change the grammatical
structure of the sentence and then even
if I take this a step further with the
help all of that is another
prepositional phrase so prepositional
phrase prepositional phrase and the way
I know it's a prepositional phrase by
the way is that I've got this in here
I've got with and so these phrases that
start with prepositions are
prepositional phrases so now I'm left
with middle school students observe
intubation and set bones and since
observe is an underlined I can even you
know stop worrying about that and just
say middle school students sets bones so
that looks like there's an error there
because sense is does not agree is
singular but I want it to be plural and
so this should be set here and so I'm
left with middle school students
observed intubation and set bones so
that was a little bit of a longer
sentence but if you if you're organized
and go through the sentence and cross
out prepositional phrases that you don't
need it can help you identify whether
the subject is what the verb is and once
you're left with just a subject in the
verb it becomes easier to read the
sentence and I and determine if the
subject and verb agree or not we'll do
one more example and then we'll move on
let's take a look
adventure climbers like Alex Honnold
specializes in free solo ascents without
ropes of sheer cliff faces such as El
Capitan and Yosemite National Park so
we've got adventure climbers so again I
want to learn about the subject here and
we've got what is the subject is it
climbers is it Alex Honnold the subject
is climbers so that's the subject now
like Alex Honnold like is another one of
those prepositions
so that's a prepositional phrase so like
Alex Honnold is not the subject and then
we have this verb here specializes so
adventure climbers specializes in free
silhouette sense without ropes
well specializes is singular but I want
it to be plural should be plural be
plural and the plural verb for
specializes is specialized and so here
we are is specializing is out and has
specialized is also out and so again
this is another example we're expecting
the sentence that you have is really
help help you simplify and go through
and find the right answer now one thing
I forgot to mention earlier before these
practice problems is that on the real
situ writing and language test you the
context that you see in the passage is
very very important and so with these
practice questions they just focus on
the grammar concept and there's no
passage but on the real thing the
context is very important and so we'll
get a chance to do that later but just
want to emphasize that in the real thing
make sure you look at what the past is
so since that's really important for
helping you figure out what the right
answer is so for now we're going to move
on to sentence punctuation and shift
gears a little bit
so sentence punctuation this is another
one of those things that you've probably
heard of heard about in English class
but maybe you forgot about a few parts
of it and so I'm going to give you a
quick overview before we do some
practice problems so to start I'm going
to start with a semicolon
and the period now these two are used to
separate two independent clauses and
what are independent clauses well they
need to have a subject and a verb if
they don't have a subject and a verb
they are not an independent clause so an
example of this is you just ignore the
second part of the sentence Yoda can
read minds semicolon I hate playing card
games against him so Yoda can read minds
is an independent clause we've got Yoda
and Ari
can read minds so what happening there
I've lost my ability to write nope I'm
back okay
and then the second part of the sentence
is also an independent clause so that's
how you know that the semicolon has been
used correctly now a comment a
conjunction is the next thing so these
are used to join clauses by converting
one Clause into a dependent clause and
so an example sentence would be George
Lucas is the creative genius but comma
but episode 3 was not his best work and
so this then is now a dependent clause
whereas George Lucas as a creative
genius is an independent clause okay and
the last thing all cover are the dash
and the colon now these two are used to
introduce a list a quote or an
explanation and the part of the sentence
that that you want to remember is that
the part of the sentence before the dash
or the colon must be an independent
clause and so that's the part that a lot
of students will forget but an example
would be Star Wars movies always start
with the same phrase and so that's an
independent clause a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away talk about that and
so this is was a quote example obviously
and as you can tell I'm a Star Wars fan
and so figured I'd write whatever
sentences made sense to me
and so this is one about saying you can
also do on whatever sentences you want
to make up to reinforce grammatical
concepts make it easier on yourself make
it interesting for you for yourself
right so now let's look at some practice
problems that will allow you to test
this concept
no president Thomas Jefferson had one
slightly unusual dream , you know just
to make this clear I'll just write
emphasize the punctuation , he hoped to
find a living woolly mammoth in the
western United States I think they were
all gone by then so he is out of luck
but President Thomas Jefferson had one
slightly unusual dream , he hoped to
find a living woolly mammoth and so I'm
going to look at this comment see if
there is a something to fix and it's so
how would I fix it well a comma I let's
see well let's let's take a look at
these the first part of this sentence
first so President Thomas Jefferson had
one slightly unusual dream that one's an
independent clause that's his right
comma he hoped to find a living woolly
mammoth from the unit western United
States that one's another independent
clause but I've only got a comma here to
separate it and so there is an error and
it's called the comma splice error and
so you're using a comma to separate two
independent clauses and that is not okay
so to join two independent clauses like
we said we need to use this a semicolon
or a period and so let's take a look at
the answer choices we know there's an
error so : no that does not separate two
independent clauses dream hoping to find
nope hmm hoping to find that one side
unusual dream he hoped it hide so then
that one is out and let me see it here
had one slightly unusual dream there
should be a semicolon hi hmm actually
this one looks like it is our winner
here
I've lost the tent again let me go
through that and so what was his dream
well he hoped to find a living woolly
mammoth and so this is the explanation
for the first part of the sentence there
and so my mistake here and so as you can
see anyone can make a mistake and that's
okay
but in this sentence we have an
independent clause and then instead of
this comma we can use this colon to
separate this next clause which is an
explanation for the first one and so in
that case the answer is B so we had that
one example now let's take a look at
another one and it gets some more
practice so this year's short week on
Discovery Channel features the rarely
seen sharks of the Cuban coral reefs and
this is a semicolon for those who can't
see it
footage includes in water and on water
activities with sharks so again here I
want to understand is there an error so
there's something to fix and it's so how
would I do it so we have this year's
Shark Week and this first Clause is an
independent clause and then footage
includes in water and on water
activities with sharks and so that one
is another independent clause and we
have this semicolon there and so I think
that actually works quite well so I have
a semicolon to separate two independent
clauses independent clause and
independent clause and so then I think
this case
the answer is going to be a now just to
go through this reef Simek semicolon
for a reef : for in the answer choice B
is not correct and it is tempting though
because it looks like this is the second
part here is related to the first Clause
but reef : would be more appropriate if
the second Clause were an example of
some of these rarely seen sharks so
because the first Clause talks about
releasing sharks and then the second
Clause talks about footage of the water
activities they're not directly they're
not tied as closely and so that one is
while tempting is not quite quite there
and then this is a semicolon and and and
so you don't need that because the
semicolon is enough by itself and then
reefs with a comma this is that comma
splice error again
okay so we've got one final example now
before we wrap up sentence punctuation
and then we'll do some questions but
let's take a look at one more sentence
it's a little bit longer but I think
you're up for it so contrary to the
popular perception that DNA was Watson
and Crick's discovery so this is just to
emphasize the colon its helical
structure and phosphate backbone were
first recognized by a woman and that one
is a semicolon
the English chemist rosalind Franklin
okay so this is a longer sentence and so
I want to break this down and really
focus in on these two parts of the
question so let's take a look just at
the colon first so contrary to the
popular perception that DNA was lost in
and Crick's discovery : its helical
structure and phosphate backbone were
first recognized by a woman so is that a
correct use of a colon is that right or
wrong check our necks
well so if you recall the the part that
precedes a colon must be an independent
clause and so that let's test that
independent clause contrary to the
popular perception that DNA was Watson
and Crick's discovery that is not an
independent clause and it's named way
because of the contrary that we have
here and so this is a dependent clause
dependent clause so this one I could
actually fix with just a comma and so I
could do that
so this semicolon is the colon is not
right and then let's move on to the next
part
so it's helical structure and phosphate
backbone were first recognized by a
woman B and then we have got a semicolon
the English chemist rosalind Franklin so
a semicolon should separate two
independent clauses and so while this
whole thing is an independent clause the
English chemist rosalind Franklin only
has a subject so no verb so that means
that's a dependent clause and so this
semicolon is incorrect and so but in
this case we could use a coal
and so let's take a look we want a comma
in a colon instead so comma and a colon
and there we go we have that here we
have this discovery
it's helical structure and oscillate
back when were first recognized by a
woman :
the English chemist rosalind Franklin
and so this takes takes a little bit of
a process but if you break down some of
the punctuation that separates each of
the clauses you it can really help
simplify and help you make sense of the
question that you're being asked so
we've done some practice questions now
we started with some that were more that
were a little simpler but then started
to get more complex as you go and as you
saw I even got I got sidetracked a
little bit there before coming back on
track and so this is a topic where the
more you practice the better you'll get
and so don't be afraid to make mistakes
or you know miss a question here there
as you're practicing so now I'm going to
pause and take a minute to answer
questions so if you have a question or
anything I've talked about go ahead and
add it in the YouTube comments there and
all the meantime I'll start answering
the questions that have already come in
okay so let's see we have a question is
SAT writing mandatory so yes it is so
it's one of the three one of the three
main sections on the test that you'll
have to take and it is that you know 35
minutes section the only part that you
might be getting confused about is the
essay so the essay is optional but the
SAT writing questions and section are
required for everyone to take let's see
what is a good way to complete the test
on time while still answering correctly
so this one I wish there were a silver
bullet answer here but it really just
comes down to practice and so the more
you practice the more familiar you'll
get with the format and structure of the
test the more the quicker you'll get at
recognizing oh this is the error here or
this is how I can improve this passage
and if you while you practice
if you time yourself that will really
help reinforce the your internal clock
of okay I've got you know 35 minutes
total I need to go at about this pace
and so once you internalize in practice
more and more it'll really help with
that we also have a number of articles
in our tips and strategies section on
Khan Academy where we go through time
management tips for math reading and
writing and so take a look there and
we'll also try and share those out as
well let's see so many grammar questions
includes logic questions such as whether
one should insert a sentence or not can
you go over how to reason those
questions over so yeah great question so
you're talking about writing questions
that ask you you know should the author
insert this sentence into the passage or
should the author delete this or should
the you know what is an example that
will bolster the author's point and
they're in those questions the context
of the passage matters and so what I
like to do is lead around that part of
the passage that is relevant so say it's
sentence number seven then I'll go back
to the passage look through and read a
little bit around it and try to
understand what is the author's goal in
that paragraph or in those paragraphs
and one way you can do that to find that
out is to read the topic sentence which
is the first sentence in the paragraph
once you read the topic sentence you can
get an understanding of okay the author
wants to talk about amphibians and how
they've spread across North America then
that gives you the background in context
you need to evaluate the answer choices
or the question of should you add it
should you add a sentence delete it so
forth and it's almost you almost want to
put yourself in the writers shoes to say
if I were making this argument or you
know informing my peers about frogs and
they're spread through North America
what I want to have this sentence where
it is what I delete it does it help the
case that I'm trying to make or not and
so I blow that down it's you know reread
the parts of the passage to understand
the author's point in the context and
then put yourself in the author's shoes
and consider does keeping or adding or
deleting the sentence most bolster your
point so that's that's how I'd approach
that we also have an article in tips and
strategies that you can check out
specifically about how to approach
inserting attendances deleting sentences
and so forth please explain the
difference between a colon and a
semicolon so the colon is is is a type
of punctuation and I'll go back here for
go back to the desktop here to explain
so a colon leads to a will leads to a a
list quote or explanation whereas a
semicolon is used to separate two
independent clauses two independent
clauses and the other thing is for a
colon the first part before the colon
also has to be an independent clause so
we have an article on two strategies
again about punctuation and that you can
cover it and review there how long or
word counts for your written portion B
and so this sounds like it's an essay
question so for the essay question it's
not about I wouldn't focus on quantity
instead I would focus on following the
prompt and so the prompt will ask you to
analyze how the author uses evidence
quotations and different rhetorical
devices to build up their argument and
so you want to make sure you focus on
the how and you are able to analyze how
they offer pieces their argument
together a common thing that many
students will do is just restate or
summarize the passages and say the
author says this and then he says that
what you want to do instead is say the
author's use of research evidence and
metaphors strengthens his argument or
claim that blah blah blah and so I
wouldn't focus so much on the links but
I would focus on honing in on that
prompt and making sure you answer that
rather than just summarizing and
restating what the author is passage was
how can you stop yourself from feeling
too anxious before and during the SAT
test so that's a great question and I
think there are a few ways you can do
that so before the test I would
encourage you to make sure you relax and
so do something that you enjoy whether
that's sports or reading or you know
hanging out with friends whatever you
want to do to relax when you're this
close to the test and you know if you're
taking the test on Saturday the most
important thing to do is to relax and
not stress yourself out so do something
that will get your mind off a test and
then during the test what you can do is
you know think back to all of the good
practice habits that you've developed
the skills that you've learned in school
along the way and that's you know just
remind yourself that hey you've done
this before you can do this and then
after the test if it turns out you
didn't feel quite good about how you did
or you're worried you can take the good
news is that you can take the SAT again
and so it's not a one chance there's not
just one chance to do it and so if you
I don't do quite as well as you hope you
can always take it again and that's
completely okay let's see okay so last
question due to the more contextualized
sentences or paragraphs how do you think
we should manage our time with the
reading and questions so this is an area
where I encourage you to experiment so
for some students they'll read through
the whole passage and then go to the
questions whereas other students will go
through the first two paragraphs and
then answer those questions and then
move on to the next two paragraphs and
then answer the questions and so test
out both of those approaches and figure
out which one works best for you what
you'll find is you know try to avoid
jumping around too much would be one
would be
a good piece of advice and so if you're
going to whatever strategy you use don't
jump around too much through the
questions because that will force you to
jump around through the passage as well
and each time you jump around through
the passage you'll have to remind
yourself wait what was the author saying
here what was the author saying over
here so on and so forth so however you
do it make sure you just go top to
bottom either paragraphs and then
questions or reading the whole passage
and then go into the questions so I
think that's all the those are all the
questions that I have time for now but
now you have an option and so I'm going
to flip back over here and right now you
have two options you can either like I
said heads the Khan Academy to do
practice problems and while there you'll
have access to the one-on-one chat
support from Khan Academy and College
Board experts or you can stay here on
YouTube and all work through a full 11
question writing passage and so this
will have all of the context and you'll
get to see what a real writing passage
looks like and so go on go ahead and
decide do you want to head to Khan
Academy or stay here both are going to
be great both will be really helpful for
you and so just pick one of those and
then I'll be back on in just a minute
either welcome back so if you've decided
to stay stay put and stay on YouTube
lines I'm now going to work through a
full writing and language practice
passage keep in mind if you change your
mind any time throughout and you're like
I'm over this guy you can head over to
Khan Academy the students won't be hurt
to practice on your own and people will
be able to chat with you one-on-one if
you have any questions but we have a
full passage ahead of us and so let's
let's take a look I'm going to start
with by reading just the first two
paragraphs of this reading passage and
so let's take a look a high profile
unelected official with the political
resources to influence domestic policy
so hi
the President of the United States has a
wife known as the first lady occupies a
unique position many first lady's not
content with simply playing the role of
a demure wife and social hostess I have
taken an active role in the political
sphere even though her power comes by
way of marriage rather than from the
electorate or the Constitution the first
lady or first gentleman has a
responsibility to capitalize on our
situation and attempt to create
significant lasting change if the
President of the United States is female
her husband's title would be first
gentlemen throughout your Kasturi there
have been a number of influential
politically engaged first ladies from
whom future first ladies and gentlemen
can take inspiration okay so before I
move on I want to make sure I understand
that passage so talking about first
lady's or first gentlemen's today and
the political role and influence that
they can have to create lasting change
and then and this last part we sound
like we're going to talk about some
first lady's in history okay so that
make sense let's keep going Abigail
Adams the second first lady in American
history was the first to assume a
protruding role in the political sphere
unlike her predecessor Martha Washington
Adams was outspoken well educated and
quickly developed a reputation of a
staunch partisan defender after openly
criticizing Congress for not declaring
war on France in 1798 her influence is
so well known that opponents claim the
president refused to make any
appointments without her approbation and
common and aspiring politicians sought
her endorsement in recent years Adams
has become a popular topic for
biographers because of her thoughts on
gender slavery and politics okay so
we're talking about Abigail Adams in
their second one and the how she's
well-spoken and well-educated so it
seems to be quite positive about her
role and so she was influential and
supportive okay so pretty positive about
her
okay now we're going to take a look at
this first question so question number
one there's no question here so this is
what's called a stemless question this
and so what that means it is that you
want to refer back to this part of the
passage where you see the one and it's
asking you should that part of the
passage be changed or not and if so how
so let's reread some of these sentences
again to get the context of the passage
so a high profile unelected official
with a political resources to influence
domestic policy the President of the
United States has a wife known as the
first lady occupies a unique position so
that probably sounds weird to you but
why does it sound weird well there's an
issue here called modifier placement
modifier placement and that really means
that you have a phrase that's meant to
modify a object and it's pretty far from
the what it's supposed to modify so that
phrase is a high-profile unelected
official with the political resources so
that's referring to the wife or the
first lady and so but the passage
doesn't have that it says we have all of
this description about the first lady or
the first gentleman and then it says the
President of the United States and so
we're not talking about the president
and so to fix that what we can do is
move this wife in this case to be a
little closer and so let's take a look
at the answer choices we know it's not
no change because there's that era the
United States has a well so we're
talking about the first lady and if you
swap in B then it's saying that the
United States is a high profile
unelected official and that does not
make a sense the country cannot be an
elected official and then the United
States president so again this one is
talking about the president and so we're
not talking about the president we're
talking about the wife and so that is
how you can go through a stimulus
question to get it and now let's keep on
going we've got that was one of eleven
and we want to I want to show you as
many different kinds of SAT writing
questions as possible so let's get right
back to it so let's take a look the
writer is considering deleting the
underlined sentence should the sentence
be kept or deleted so this is an example
of one of the questions that was
earlier how do I approach a deletion or
addition question and so what I want to
do then is the first decision I try to
make is if I want to keep or delete and
what you'll notice is in these questions
I've got two keeps and I've got two
deletes and so if I decide if I can make
this decision around about if I should
keep or delete and really it helps me
narrow it down just to two and so what I
want to do is take a look at this
paragraph and make sure I understand the
context and determine if this really
helps the flow of the passage of the
paragraph and reinforce the author's
point or if it detracts from it so let
me just read from here about here down
to here so even though her power comes
by way of marriage rather than from the
electorate of the Constitution the first
lady or first gentleman has
responsibility to capitalize on our
situation and attempt to create
significant lasting change if the
President of the United States of female
her husband's title would be First
Gentleman and then I fade throughout
history there have been a number of
influential or politically engaged first
ladies from whom we can draw inspiration
okay so let's think about that flow
there does this second sentence here add
or detract from the author's point in
the logical flow of the paragraph well
it seems like we're talking about you
know the first lady and the
responsibility and the opportunity that
that the person has and then about the
all these influential historical first
ladies and so it feels a bit random to
me to have this blurb about the first
gentleman because it seems more like a
factoid and so I think it doesn't help
with the passage and somebody go ahead
and cross those off and then let's look
at C and D deleted because it interrupts
the introduced introduction of the
passages main point with a loosely
related detail so that's pretty much
what I said because I there's so there's
the factoid that I don't think it is
relevant and so that's a pretty positive
feeling good about that let's take a
look at D deleted because it weakens the
passages influence on the importance of
work done by several influential first
ladies so I don't think it does
yes it does it's a random factoid but it
does not the real harm of the it is not
that it weakens the emphasis and so C is
the right final answer okay let's keep
going then to question number three
which choice is most consistent with the
writers position that's established in
the passage so which choice is most
consistent with the writers position as
established in the passage and so this
is another one of those stemless
questions and so I'd look at question
number three here so Abigail Adams the
second first lady in American history
was the first to assume a protruding
role we've got a protruding role in the
political sphere unlike her predecessor
and all of that okay so and remember
this this paragraph was pretty positive
about Abigail Adams and so we want to
understand its protruding hips and is
consistent with the writers position and
can be protruding sounded a bit odd when
I first read it and so protruding seems
like the the meaning of protruding is
that of something that is sticking out
in some way and so too given that the
author is pretty positive about Abigail
Adams to say that she was the first
first lady to really stick out in kind
of a negative way makes me think that
that's probably out so let's take a look
at be an obtrusive role so obtrusive
again also has a similar meaning to
protruding and that it's sticking out
that in a slightly negative way so
that's negative that's negative and so
we can cross that out and then what
about a prominence first to assume a
prominent role in the political sphere
so that has a connotation that's
positive and you know is positive and
roughly means influential significant
and so that one I like and then last one
an ostentatious role in this political
sphere so that one again is slightly
negative and has a negative connotation
connotation or meaning and so then my
final answer here is going to be C now I
like the question because there were
some words in here that
you don't use everyday language so I
don't I don't know you probably don't go
with your friends and say hey you're
really awesome tations because not you
know so there are some words that you
might not be as familiar with and so
vocab is something that may come up in
the SAT and so what you can do there is
any time you encounter an SAT word on
the SAT that you don't understand write
it down and go take a look and look it
up and so that you don't come across
that word again and then you're like ah
I didn't look it up at one time and I
still don't know it now and here it is
again and you know you want to avoid
that situation and so that's what I've
encouraged you to do and the more you
read and the more you practice on the
SAT the more familiar you'll get with
some of these words so let's keep on
going
so question number four and then change
her so protruding a little her influence
is so well known that opponents claimed
the president refused to make any
appointments without her approbation so
is is that correct well what I want to
look at here is the verb tense in these
other in the rest of the sentence and so
I've got claimed refused and so those
are all past tense and so I want
something that's past tense and so I
think was would fix it her influence was
so well known that opponents claim the
president refused and so there we go I
have my answer of beep all right moving
right along we're running a little short
on time here so let's see which choice
most effectively concludes the paragraph
so we're going to look here at this part
and let's see we're talking about
Abigail Adams her prominent role and how
she's very outspoken and we have in
recent years there's a popular she's
become a popular topic so okay that's
pretty positive and so but I want
something that links back to this topic
sentence here and so this is where I'm
looking here and so she was the second
first lady and was the first to assume a
prominent role and so I want something
positive that also ties back to this
topic sentence okay so let's take a look
at B in a period of limited female
autonomy ad
demonstrated that the first lady could
substantially influence politics in the
United States so yeah that is very
positive and also ties back to this
influence politics in the United States
and then in the topic sentence over here
we're talking about an influential role
in the political sphere so I actually
think that one works better than a so I
can go ahead and cross that one off and
then a major component of Adam's legacy
is a collection of more than a hunk 1100
letters written between Adams and our
husband so that is another random fact
that detracts and so we're not talking
of the about these letters it it's all
about the author is really focusing on
no on let me new man there sorry it's
really focusing on the on Abigail
herself not these letters and so then
the last part I'll just zoom in a little
bit more here Abigail Adams was not only
the wife of the second US president but
also the mother of the sixth US
President John Quincy Adams so again
that one is talking about the mother
and rather than Abigail Adams and so be
there's going to be our final answer
that some feedback that I should zoom in
more so I will do my best to do that in
the second half of the passage first
let's read the tech announcement passage
and then we'll tackle the questions
okay from 1933 to 1945 Eleanor Roosevelt
was intimately involved in her husband's
domestic policies during the tumultuous
Great Depression so intimately involved
for example she spearheaded the
establishment of Arthurdale artha there
was a resettlement community that
combined subsistence farming and simple
industry for impoverished mine workers
after convincing her husband to bring
the project under federal authorities
Roosevelt became the unofficial project
director in support of the community
through regular visits and budgetary
oversight
however she became however that's a
funny word to user she became beloved by
the American people who admired her
commitment to helping those in need
admired her commitment to helping those
in need so this time we're talking about
mrs. Roosevelt here and the positive
impact she had on policies and the Great
Depression and she was quite well loved
by the American people so hard okay
let's keep going here two decades later
clàudia Lady Bird Johnson pushed further
into the into the political sphere than
had any previous first lady she attended
legislative strategy sessions and
directly interacted with Congress to
garner support for her environmental
legislation okay I environmentalist
Wishon Johnson established her legacy by
using her political leverage to
influence the passage nearly 200
environmental laws well a lot of a lot
of law that she's helped have so despite
the important contribution these first
lady's made to American society her
activism often resulted in scathing
critique Adams was mockingly called mrs.
president Roosevelt was ridiculed in
newspapers and a Montana billboard read
impeached Lady Bird yet as Barbara Bush
aptly noted the first lady is going to
be criticized no matter what she does
first ladies have a responsibility to
ignore the inevitable criticism they
should use the position to create
invaluable social and political change
as they have for centuries
okay so we have we talked about so far
miss Roosevelt miss Johnson here and
then about the need for first ladies to
make change regardless so let's take a
look now at question number six which
the option most effectively combines the
sentences at the underlined portion so
we're looking at number six here so
Arthurdale
at the for example she spearheaded the
establishment of Arthurdale period
Arthurdale was a resettlement community
that combines subsistence funny okay so
it's grammatically correct but i think i
could improve the clarity here and
streamline it and so i might want to use
a comma would be a good one and then
delete that and so that would be the
simplest solution to that but let's take
a look at the answer choices Arthurdale
and it was a resettlement community that
is combined not not quite so not not
quite Arthurdale comma okay so that one
is combines the sentences effectively
and it's very streamlined and so I like
that one our third Oh semicolon it was a
resettlement community so that one is
okay but it's not a streamlined as the
first as be instead of the sound and
then occidental comma this being the
name of so you don't need to say that
it's bit repetitive because you know
that you're talking about Arthurdale and
then this is explaining what it is and
so the answer trace is B let's keep
going here on to number seven so this is
another one of those stemless questions
and we want to look at here number seven
and say let's read a little bit before
and a little bit after to get the
context again context is super important
so after convincing her husband to bring
the project under federal authority
Roosevelt became the unofficial project
director and supported the community
through regular visits and budgetary
oversight however if she became beloved
by the American people who admired her
commitment to helping those in most in
need so is that the right word for
numbers in number seven so however it
doesn't feel quite right because all of
this passage is quite positive about
Eleanor Roosevelt and so to say however
indicates that there should be a
contrast and there isn't a contrast
there so we don't want to contrast it
should be something like there for so
she's done all of these great things and
she's been influential therefore she was
loved would make a lot more sense than
this contrasting phrase and so it's not
no change for instance she became up
that's not quite doesn't quite match my
therefore here in keeping with this
tradition no we're not talking about
tradition so that's up and then as a
result of these efforts so there we go
that one almost exactly matches my
therefore prediction and fits with the
flow of the passage that says you know
she is very influential she did all of
you create things therefore as a result
of these efforts she became well-loved
so we are almost through to the end only
three more questions and so we'll keep
going through just so you see a few more
question types and then I'll close with
a few final tips for those of you who
are taking the SAT on Saturday so
question number eight
so I'll just zoom in on the question
because this is a lengthy question here
so you can take a look at this point the
writer wants to provide an example of
legislation mentioned in the previous
sentence which choice most effectively
accomplished this accomplishes this goal
so we want an example of legislation
okay so we'll come back to the advance
of choices but first I want to look back
at the context so this is question
number eight and so we're talking about
Lady Bird Johnson so we're looking here
and so two decades later she pushed
further in the political sphere she
attended legislative strategy sessions
and directly interacted with Congress to
garner support for her environmental
legislation so bingo there is the
environmental legislation we are talking
about and okay so we want an example of
environmental legislation and so let's
see which of these answer choices best
accomplishes that and I'll move back
here for now so one such legislative
efforts the Beautification Act of 1965
improves the environment surrounding
America's highways by eliminating
billboards and junkyards and adding
scenic landscaping well I've got
legislative effort there and I've got to
act and I've got to build so anytime you
see an answer choice key that matches a
lot of the language in the passage
that's generally a good sign so I'm
feeling good here let's take a look
though at the other ones after her
husband signed into law the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 Johnson went on a solo
multi-state speaking tours in southern
US to advocate for her husband and
advances policies so talking about the
Civil Rights Act in this case and rather
than about Johnson's legislations
herself and it's also not about the
environment so that's out ladybirds
beautification directed had begun when
she formed the first lady's committee
which focused on urban decay in planted
millions of flowers so this one is about
the environment so I like that but it's
not as strong an answer as this one and
so I don't have the laws that are being
passed and so that one's not as strong
as aim and then the last one in support
of the government see America first
campaign Johnson undertook a series of
trips to national parks to highlight the
natural beauty of the American outdoors
and promote ecotourism so again this one
talks about the environment but then
what about the law part so that one's
out and so my final answer here is eight
so just a few more questions here
let's take a look question number nine
so the stemless question and so we're
going to take a look at option number
nine
despite the important contributions
these first ladies made to American
Society and I'll zoom in here her
activism often resulted in skating
critiques so I'll just focus on this her
part here so despite the important
contributions these first ladies made
her activism often resulted so this is a
pronoun her and what's the what is the
pronoun referring to so point
contributions these first lady so this
is the the anticipatory what the pronoun
is referring to so first lady's and her
well first her doesn't quite work
because first lady's is plural if I go
back up here I want the plural pronoun
so there would be this one and so their
contribution so there is this one is
long because this is they are so it's
not possessive and there is more like
over there okay nope
and question number ten let's go back
over here okay her activism often
resulted in skating critiques : Adams
was mockingly called mrs. president
okay so resultant of skating critiques
that seems clear and I don't see an
error here with the Senate with a coal
in there and the part before the : is an
independent clause so that seems right
so I actually don't think there is
anything wrong here so then go ahead and
go with that and so in this case I'm
able to choose a because I am familiar
with I was able to confirm that it was
clear so there's clarity and it was also
correct
and so clarity is you know more of a the
more you practice the better you'll
understand what is clear enough and what
is not and then in terms of grammatical
correctness it's more about familiarity
with the standard English conventions
and paying attention in English class
but so knowing those two allows me to
hone in on a a little bit quicker and
then last question so mockingly called
and in peace a bush yes as Barbara Bush
aptly noted the first lady is going to
be criticized no matter what she does so
yet comma as Barbara Bush comma aptly
noted the first lady is going to be
criticized no matter what she does okay
so is there an issue here so yet comma
looks good as Barbara Bush comma aptly
noted so I don't think I need this
second comma because this is all part of
the same prepositional phrase so as
Barbara Bush aptly noted so I don't
think I need that second one and that
should be a thing so yet comma as
Barbara Bush hastily noted comma okay
yep so that one gets me there so yet as
the comma there that placement is wrong
we know that it's not no change and then
yet as well I'm missing a comma here so
that one's out and yeah so there we
aren't now we've gone through a full
writing passage now and I know there was
some jumping around and some zooming
so it was a bit harder to follow along
Paul use for that
hopefully this give you a good example
of what it's like to work through a full
SAT writing and language passage and
also shows you how important it is to
take the context of the passage into
consideration that's all for SAT writing
in language for now but to just close
things out for those of you who are
taking the SAT this Saturday I just want
to share a few final tips so that 50 is
in two days so number one relax
don't try and cram don't I you know try
and review all 20 pages of your notes
beforehand just do something that will
help you relax and hang out with friends
or read a book or watch TV play some
video games whatever floats your boat
and then that's the one thing you should
do before Saturday morning is to prepare
your backpack with everything prepare
all of your materials for test day so
that is your number two pencils your
photo ID your calculator your admission
ticket and how you figure out how you're
going to get there on the morning of so
that you're not rushed or flustered on
when you wake up and the last thing is
just to get a good night's rest at eat
well the night before and you know trust
yourself that you've been practicing and
you're you're ready to take the test and
no matter hopefully you do well but if
not remember you can always take the
exam again
so that is all that I have for you today
I hope this was helpful today's class is
helpful along with the SAT reading and
math classes that we hosted before for
those easily taking the test on Saturday
best of luck and for everyone else keep
practicing keep working hard and good
luck to you take care
you